if anyone would have picked an  all-american team I think certainly the  two people who would present the award  for the best performance by an actor  would be the first team Miss Irene Dunne  and mr. John Wayne  hmm well John you're the quarterback on  this team so you start calling signals  all right coach  nominated for Best Performance by an  actor our Tony Curtis in the Defiant  ones Paul Newman in Cat on a Hot Tin  Roof David Nevin in separate tables  Sidney Poitier in the Defiant ones  Spencer Tracy and old man in the sea and  the winner Irene David Niven  I'm so loaded Diamond Goodluck charms I  could hardly make it up the steps  Oh people have been saying thank you for  Oscars for 30 years and I have nothing  to add except thank you